hey everybody its charlie oh my god we
just had like the most amazing four
hours of TV crossover that we've ever
seen in the DC Universe before this is
going to be my legends video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet and there is a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter that is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video be sure to turn
alerts on we have the finales coming
next week but let's talk about the crazy
crossover we learn about how Supergirl
is going to come back in the back half
of the season for another flash
crossover so I'll try to explain all
that stuff and then I'm going to do a
separate video tomorrow
for what I think they're going to do
next year for the big four-way crossover
because even though arrow is in its
fifth season they even had a reference
about how this all started with us that
was what that line between Sarah and
Oliver was you know double meaning it
all started with us on the boat but it
also started with the arrow TV show like
the big air over so I'll try to explain
all that as I work through Easter eggs
and top ten but here we go number ten
Oliver asks Cara to sit this one out
because she's an unknown quantity and he
feels like he can't trust her I know it
felt like he was being a super dick to
her any kind of was like he was keeping
her at arm's length just because he only
has like so much weirdness that he can
process but you could also think of it
as him being kind of like a battle
commander like you need to fully
understand and trust all the people on
your team and he just felt like he
couldn't trust car yet because he didn't
know her that well but that all changed
by the end of the episode so they also
kind of did the same thing with Cisco
and Barry I know a lot of you are like
why is Cisco being such a dick to Barry
number nine Cisco finally comes around
on Barry after he realizes that he also
derps in the past making the future
invasion that much worse so number eight
Cisco Felicity and part of the legends
go back into the past to capture
Dominator and find out what the hell is
going on so they go back to that viral
footage from 1951 we get to see citizens
steal in his comic book costume for the
first time and heatwave just barbecues
one of the dominators in the nuts it was
pretty hilarious but then they get taken
in and it turns into this big x-files
storyline so number seven WT
they have their own version of the
smoking man so the minute he showed up
in the past I knew that he was the same
old man in the future that had been
there when the first president was taken
so I was like okay they're doing an
x-files thing where you have an evil
part of the government that tries to
collude with the dominators make a deal
for their survival it's right out of
classic x-files there was this big
storyline during x-files we're aliens
bad aliens were invading in a group of
humans including the smoking man
colluded with them in order to ensure
their survival so like this is their
version of that smoking man who is now
being sent to Antarctica but because
Sisko and Felicity are there this whole
time they're just all kinds of movie
references being dropped
so the hypnotic supersonic funky-fresh
is a sierra song felicity throws up
twice and just starts making up words
because she can't speak right one of the
gibberish phrases that she speaks is
right out of a Star Trek The Next
Generation episode she says Darmok odd
Jalad Austin Gras that's right out of an
episode where Captain Picard has to
understand this alien is speaking some
different language and he just keeps
saying that phrase over and over they
dropped the Princess Bride reference
Cisco drops a Spielberg reference which
is War of the Worlds then when they
figure out they need to save them he
drops a stranger things out out men in
black set your phasers to stun which is
obviously Star Trek so there were just
pages and pages of Cisco and Felicity
movie references number 6 Martin Stein's
mystery daughter turns out she's like
this super engineer just like Ray Palmer
knows all about nanotechnology but she
turns into one of the emotional
foundations of the story for firestorm
but early on just a look on kaitlin's
face when she figured out that Martin
Stein was going to erase her after they
were done with all this like you're just
gonna go back and just wink her out of
existence but obviously he comes full
circle and he asks Jax to keep the
secret from the team so just remember
now that Martin Stein has a big secret
from the rest of the team but they
always say that like the best characters
have a secret that nobody else knows
about but the problem with firestorm is
that they share a mind so there are no
secrets between Jax and Martin Stein so
that's why he had to make that deal with
Jax at the end but number
five they learn in present day that the
dominators are after berry because of
Flashpoint they had come in the past to
1951 because they detected metahumans it
just wanted to see what was up they knew
about the JSA so in the future when they
detected the changes in the timeline
because a flash point that's when they
came back so Barry has to sacrifice
himself or they'll kill all metahumans
and just because the bomb they're using
is so big it'll kill a bunch of regular
people too so Barry Allen just always
gets the shaft anytime the universe is
on the line
crisis on Infinite Earths during
flashpoint he has to let the
reverse-flash go back and kill his
mother again like he has to willingly
let him kill his mother
so as cool as it would be to have the
powers of the flash the more powerful
you get in the comics the bigger
sacrifices you're asked to make but
number four it says go back in the
present uses the transponder he stole
off the alien ship to vibe him in
citizens steal up and find out what's
going on so as nice as the Dominator is
he's like yeah we can't give you Barry
we're totally gonna take him we're
totally gonna blow up your race any even
compliment Cisco on being a metahuman
right before he tells them about the
bomb there's gonna kill all metahumans
so even with all the crazy vibes stuff
that Cisco did in the episode he's still
not wearing the comic book costume in
present-day he doesn't quite have the
gauntlets on all the time that will
probably change in the back half of the
season I'm guessing by season four he'll
at least start wearing the costume and
hopefully they can find a way for killer
frost to use her powers too but we can
talk about that when I post my flash
video next week but number three
Barry tries to give them the speech
about how he's going to sacrifice
himself the team will let him is this
big rally moment you know you're part of
the crew we roll out together so they
have their big rollout where they all
stand in formation in number two they
have their Captain America Civil War
Airport battle scene just big action set
piece
Oliver falls off the building Cara saves
him and then Cara and Barry have to run
all over the world at SuperSpeed race
around the world and try to attach all
the devices to the dominators they beat
him off then they get the
congratulations from the new president
who tells them that it
has to be secret but they had this extra
long establishing shot of the Hall of
Justice
just to let you know that this is going
to continue to be a big thing in number
one all the after party just like
everybody saying their goodbyes cisco
gives cara the device that will allow
her to open breaches so that she can
come back for crossovers anytime she
wants she can call them anytime she
wants so very clearly this is what
they're going to use to get her back on
the flash for the second crossover in
the back half of the season so if you
didn't know there's going to be a
Supergirl crossover with the flash just
with the flash not with the other TV
shows in the second half of the season
it's going to be like their musical
episode we don't know a whole lot about
it now like what the twist is going to
be why it's going to be a musical so
that's a long ways off don't worry about
it now it's just that they have a easy
way to get car on for crossovers now but
they said it only works for one person
Ray Palmer has that really funny moment
with car where Brandon Rath is like hey
she looks kind of like my cousin just a
nice wink at the fact that he used to be
Superman I've been waiting for them to
do that they haven't done that many
Superman Brandon Roth jokes but one of
my favorite like deep meaning lines was
that sarah oliver moment where she's
like this all started with us so like I
said you know double meaning it all
started on the boat the Queen's Gambit
with all this craziness but the arrow
verse the big crossover just all the
stuff that's happening now started with
them Oliver makes a nice reference to
being in the dream land during the arrow
hundredth episode I don't need to wonder
what my life would have been like they
actually gave us that gift and I like my
life the way it is now it's better
complicated which is kind of the speech
that he had with Barry when they have
drinks like they did after the first
arrow flash crossover where they had
like the Rocky team-up match like who
would win in a fight like they're
sitting there drinking who would win in
a fight like they're still having that
drunk guy comic book argument but I feel
like it was a great episode it was a
nice bookend to the crossover the
episode itself but the crossover the
four night crossover or three night
crossover however you want to think
about it
was a really good couple hours of
television that felt like a movie but
the impressive thing is that they were
able to do it on a TV budget and
especially like a CW budget which isn't
a major Network so they don't have major
Network money but let me know what was
your favor
moment from this episode what was your
favorite crossover moment I did like all
the funny weird moments but definitely
like their big comic-book rollout was
probably my favorite at least from this
episode but now we got to talk about
what we want them to do next year with
the crossover I'll talk about that in a
separate video specific storylines I
want them to do but Manhunters or a
giant legion of doom team-up it just has
to be a threat that's big enough to
merit all of the supers like you don't
need super girl to fight damian darhk--
or malcolm merlyn you need super girl to
fight somebody from outer space some
like giant big super strong person but
like I said these big team ups drive
ratings so hardcore arrow like doubled
its ratings it's up seventy-seven
percent across the board for the entire
season and that's just one example so I
think what they'll try to do is that is
arrow slowly goes off the air they'll
try to do another big team-up show like
Teen Titans that's why you've been
hearing a lot of live-action Teen Titans
talk lately because they already have
most of those characters on all these
four shows so if one of them goes off
the air they can just bring the others
on to the other shows in once they have
enough and once they have the space in
the schedule the money to do it they can
just do a full-blown Teen Titans show so
I will do like a Teen Titans video in
the next week or two and I know a lot of
you been asking about Young Justice
stuff but also a congratulations to the
winner of this round of the giveaway
Kevin Lopez you win one of the flash
rings please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there is a new round
that's already going right now so I'll
announce the winner for that the next
time I post a DC video so tomorrow
there's a whole bunch of stuff happening
there's a rumor that there's going to be
a spider-man homecoming trailer if there
is I'll totally do a video for it but
I've also got Rick and Morty then I've
got the video for next year's crossover
so there'll be a whole bunch of stuff
posting in the next couple of days while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for that big flash trailer
for next week and you can click here for
all the other crossover videos thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight